Some people, they read those old stories from 3,000 years ago, The Iliad and The Odyssey. They read them in school, and it just gets to them. One of the producers here at our show, Emanuele, was like that.
有些人会去读3000年前的那些古老故事，《伊利亚特》和《奥德赛》。他们在学校里读这些书，然后就深陷其中了。我们节目的制片人之一埃马努埃莱就是这样。
I loved the heroes, Hector. I thought Agamemnon was such a diva. I loved The Aeneid. We had to translate it in my Latin class. And in addition to translating passages, I decided to make, like, a 9x3 foot mural out of magazine paper depicting Aeneas' journey into hell.
我热爱英雄赫克托耳。我觉得阿伽门农真是个戏精。我喜欢《埃涅阿斯纪》。我们在拉丁语课上得翻译它。除了翻译段落，我还决定用杂志纸做一幅9x3英尺的壁画，描绘埃涅阿斯进入地狱的过程。
Wait, when you say magazine paper, you mean you're cutting letters out of a magazine, like a serial killer?
等等，你说杂志纸是什么意思？你是说像连环杀手那样从杂志上剪下字母吗？
I mean, I was-- no, I mean, I was meticulously ripping teeny pieces of different colors of magazine paper and making, like, a mosaic basically.
不是，我是说……不是，我是说，我当时在一丝不苟地撕下不同颜色杂志纸的小碎片，基本上是在做一个马赛克拼贴画。
Oh, I see.
哦，我明白了。
And I remember that J.Lo was on the mural for some reason, because she was wearing, like, a white dress that kind of looked Grecian, so.
我记得不知为什么，詹妮弗·洛佩兹也在那幅壁画上，因为她当时穿的白色连衣裙看起来有点像希腊风格的，所以。
It was like a toga-y dress.
那就像一件托加长袍似的裙子。
Yeah, yeah, yeah. So she got to be Dido in hell.
对，对，对。所以她就成了地狱里的狄多。
When a teacher assigned a 20-page research paper on any subject in the world, like they could do anything at all, it was obvious to Emanuele what to do-- the story of Troy, the place where the Trojan War happened, the walled city that they pulled the Trojan horse into.
当老师布置一篇关于世界上任何主题的20页研究论文时，他们可以选任何题目，埃马努埃莱很清楚自己要做什么——特洛伊的故事，特洛伊战争发生的地方，他们拉入特洛伊木马的那座围城。
And in doing research for this project, I found out about this guy named Heinrich Schliemann.
在为这个项目做研究时，我发现了海因里希·施里曼这个人。
Heinrich Schliemann, a man who also read those old stories and got obsessed.
海因里希·施里曼，一个也读过那些古老故事并为此着迷的男人。
He's born in Germany in the 1800s. He's like a business man, a merchant in Russia. And then he moved to California during the Gold Rush and opened a bank. It's said that he would carry around, like, copies of Homer. And he taught himself ancient Greek.
他19世纪出生在德国。他是个商人，在俄罗斯做生意。后来在淘金热期间他搬到了加利福尼亚，开了一家银行。据说他总是随身携带荷马史诗的副本。他还自学了古希腊语。
Like in two years, he taught himself ancient Greek, which is insane to me, just so he could read the books in the language of origin. Anyway, but basically, he amasses this huge fortune. And once he has this fortune, he decides that he's going to find Troy. At the time, people weren't sure if it was a real place or just, like, a story, like Atlantis.
比如在两年内，他自学了古希腊语，这对我来说太疯狂了，只是为了能用原文读这些书。总之，他积累了一笔巨大的财富。一旦有了钱，他就决定要找到特洛伊。在当时，人们不确定那是一个真实的地方，还是像亚特兰蒂斯那样只是一个故事。
And I know this is kind of a dumb question, but in that period, did archaeologists even exist? Was that even a job yet?
我知道这可能是一个愚蠢的问题，但在那个时期，考古学家已经存在了吗？那还算是一种职业吗？
It's not really a job. It's like a very new field, this whole idea of digging up the past. And so there are like sort of hobbyists dabbling in it.
那时候这还算不上一种职业。这只是一个非常新的领域，挖掘过去的整个想法才刚刚兴起。所以有一些类似业余爱好者的人在涉足这个领域。
But these hobbyists by the 1870s have figured out from various geographic clues that Homer gives in the text about Troy's proximity to the Dardanelles and to Mount Ida. They figured out where a likely location for the city might be. It was in the place that we now call Turkey. And at that spot was kind of a big mound of dirt. And Schliemann gets going.
但到了1870年代，这些业余爱好者已经从荷马在文中提供的关于特洛伊靠近达达尼尔海峡和伊达山的各种地理线索中，找出了这座城市可能的位置。它就在我们现在称为土耳其的地方。那个地点有一大堆土堆。于是施里曼开始了挖掘。
So he starts to dig. He hires dozens and dozens of workers. And when he's digging, he starts to find basically like these layers of cities that are sort of built on top of each other. So there's bits of pottery and foundations of buildings. When a city burned to the ground, they would just build another city right on top of it.
所以他开始挖掘。他雇佣了几十上百名工人。在他挖掘的过程中，他开始发现基本上是一层层叠在一起的城市。有陶器碎片和建筑物地基。当一座城市被烧毁时，他们就会在原址上直接再建一座新城市。
Right.
没错。
But none of them are what he's looking for. What he is looking for is he wants to find basically gold, silver, and bronze. That's the thing he thinks is going to be the signifier that this is Troy. Because he's thinking of this treasure rich city that Homer describes in The Iliad. And he's also thinking that, well, it's got to be further down. It has to be at the bottom, right? Troy is going to be at the bottom of this pile. And so he keeps digging.
但这些都不是他要找的。他想要找的是黄金、白银和青铜。他认为这才是特洛伊的标志。因为他想的是《伊利亚特》中荷马描述的那座宝藏丰富的城市。他还认为，嗯，它一定在更深的地方。它必须在最底部，对吧？特洛伊应该在这个土堆的最底层。于是他继续挖掘。
And he keeps finding more and more layers with cities.
他不断发现越来越多的城市层。
Yes. And then he gets to the bottom of these piles of cities. And that's where he finds this treasure. He finds exactly what he's looking for. He finds this gold. He finds the silver. He finds bronze. He calls it Priam's treasure, Priam being the king of Troy in The Iliad. He says--
是的。然后他到达了这些城市堆积物的底部。那就是他发现宝藏的地方。他找到了他要找的东西。他发现了金子，发现了银子，发现了青铜。他称之为“普里阿摩斯的宝藏”，普里阿摩斯是《伊利亚特》中特洛伊的国王。他说——
But there's nothing on it that says, like, Priam's--
但上面并没有写着“普里阿摩斯”之类的字样……
He didn't write his name.
他没写上自己的名字。
You've reached Priam's bank or something. No, OK.
“你已到达普里阿摩斯的银行”之类的。不，好吧。
No. No, nothing like that.
不。不，没有那种东西。
He doesn't have hard proof that it's Troy. He doesn't find writing, which would have really helped. Can I ask one question?
他没有确凿证据证明这就是特洛伊。他没有发现文字记录，那本会对考证有很大帮助。我可以问一个问题吗？
Yeah.
可以。
Did he find a huge wooden horse? 'Cause that would have nailed it.
他找到巨大的木马了吗？因为那就能盖棺定论了。
No huge wooden horse. Wouldn't have survived.
没有巨大的木马。那东西保存不下来的。
Hm. OK.
嗯。好吧。
I'm sorry.
抱歉。
Fine.
没关系。
Today's show is about the inadvertent things that happen when you start digging up the past. And this is the point where Schliemann's story gets more complicated. Schliemann announces to the world that he's found the city that Homer was writing about. He's found Troy. He becomes internationally famous.
今天的节目是关于当你开始挖掘过去时发生的意外之事。这就是施里曼的故事变得更加复杂的地方。施里曼向世界宣布，他找到了荷马所写的那个城市。他找到了特洛伊。他变得举世闻名。
But the truth of the situation is, is that the Troy at the bottom of the pile, with all this treasure and all this gold, that actually was not Troy. It was not Homer's Troy, at least. Like, that's from thousands of years before Troy would have even happened. The Troy that he was looking for was actually one of the cities that he had just dug through and destroyed in the process of digging through it.
但事实情况是，堆积物最底层的那个拥有所有这些财宝和黄金的城市，其实并不是特洛伊。至少不是荷马笔下的特洛伊。那是比特洛伊的历史还要早几千年的遗迹。他要找的那个特洛伊，实际上是他在此过程中刚刚挖穿并摧毁掉的城市之一。
So in other words, he's just digging down. He reaches Troy. He's like, no, no, this isn't it-- throws it on the side as, like, debris.
所以换句话说，他只是向下挖掘。他到达了特洛伊。他却觉得“不，不，不是这个”——然后把它当成碎片扔在了一边。
Yeah.
是的。
That's garbage.
那是垃圾。
Yeah. And basically, he destroyed a big chunk of the ancient city in trying to find the city.
是的。基本上，他在寻找这座城市的过程中摧毁了那座古城的一大片区域。
The Troy he was looking for archaeologists understand now was just three layers down, and he dug nine layers down.
考古学家现在明白，他要找的特洛伊其实就在上面三层，但他却挖到了第九层。
So what this means is that for any archaeologist today who's trying to figure out anything that's going on at Troy, he kind of screwed them over. I called one of these guys. His name is Brian Rose, and he was the co-director of excavations at Troy for 25 years. He's not a fan of Schliemann.
这意味着对于今天任何试图研究特洛伊遗迹的考古学家来说，他简直是害苦了他们。我采访了其中一位，他叫布莱恩·罗斯，他在特洛伊担任挖掘联席主管长达25年。他不是施里曼的粉丝。
So he didn't really know what he was doing. So there's a lot of information that we've lost on account of his speed and digging. When I look through his notebooks, he'll say something like, "Byzantine building and debris found today, dismantled." Now that doesn't tell me if it's early, middle, late Byzantine, what the building looked like. Was it many rooms? Was it only one room? What did he find there? Or was it just debris that was in his way?
他其实根本不知道自己在做什么。因为他挖掘的速度太快，我们丢失了大量信息。当我翻看他的笔记本时，他会写类似“今天发现拜占庭建筑和碎片，已拆除”之类的话。但这并没有告诉我那是什么时期的拜占庭建筑——早期、中期还是晚期？那建筑长什么样？是有很多房间？还是只有一个房间？他在那里发现了什么？或者那只是挡他路的碎片？
Debris that was in his way that Schliemann would just dig up and throw in a pile on the side.
挡他路的碎片，施里曼就会直接挖出来扔在一旁的堆里。
Yeah, Schliemann excavated extensively, and he had to put the earth that he removed somewhere. Schliemann dumped all the earth from his trenches in the areas where I want to dig.
是的，施里曼进行了大规模的挖掘，他不得不把清理出来的土堆在某个地方。施里曼把他所有挖掘出来的土都倾倒在了我想挖掘的区域。
And part of the reason that he wants to dig in that area is because there might be writing there.
他想在那个区域挖掘的部分原因，是因为那里可能存在文字记录。
And so Schliemann has now made that very hard.
所以施里曼现在让这变得非常困难。
Yeah, because there's all this dirt, all these uprooted ruins that are just on top of that area. And then it would take years and, Brian says, technology that doesn't even exist now to dig it up without doing more damage.
是的，因为那里堆满了泥土，还有所有被铲掉的废墟。布莱恩说，要在那块区域挖掘而不造成进一步破坏，需要花费数年时间，而且还需要现在根本不存在的技术。
So you have 20 meters of dump through which you would have to go in order to get to a deposit that might have writing of Late Bronze Age date. That's something I'd love to be able to do. But for now, it's just too monumental an undertaking to do it.
所以你得先清理掉20米的垃圾堆，才能到达那个可能藏有青铜时代晚期文字的沉积层。那是我想做的事，但目前来说，这实在是一项太浩大的工程。
One of the things that has always kind of bugged me about this story is that before Schliemann died, they actually figured out that he was wrong.
关于这个故事，一直困扰我的一点是，在施里曼去世之前，他们实际上已经发现他搞错了。
Oh, they did?
哦，他们发现了？
Yeah, but he's still remembered to this day for discovering Troy. And one of the things I remember from that paper I wrote was that I really ended up mad at him. Like-- [LAUGHS] I was mad at him for, like--
是的，但他至今仍因发现特洛伊而被人们铭记。我记得我写的论文中有一点，我最终真的很生他气。就像——[笑] 我气他……
Like you were going to go visit Troy, and he messed it up for you.
就像你本来打算去参观特洛伊，结果被他搞砸了。
Basically, kind of. But when I talked with Brian about it, he's kind of zen about it.
基本算是吧。但当我跟布莱恩谈起这件事时，他看得很开。
I would certainly express frustration with Schliemann in the same way that an archaeologist digging at Troy in 100 years would express frustration with me.
我当然会像100年后在特洛伊挖掘的考古学家对我感到沮丧一样，对施里曼感到沮丧。
Oh, I like his attitude.
哦，我喜欢他的态度。
Yeah, I mean, I think when you're an archaeologist, you kind of have to take the long view. You're aware that people are going to come after you, and they're going to know more than you. So you're very aware of your own limitations.
是的，我认为当你成为一名考古学家时，你必须放长眼光。你要意识到在你之后还会有人来，他们会比你懂得更多。所以你对自己局限性的认知是非常清楚的。
And that's actually our show today. Today on our program, we have all kinds of people going and digging up stuff from the past, full of hope, but definitely with their own limitations. And the search changes things. From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Stay with us.
这其实就是我们今天的节目主题。今天在节目中，我们有各种各样的人怀揣希望去挖掘过去，但他们当然都有各自的局限性。而这种探索本身就会改变事物。这里是芝加哥WBEZ电台，《美国生活》节目。我是艾拉·格拉斯。请继续收听。
Act One, Family Plot. We move now from the losers of the Trojan War to the winners-- or anyway, the descendants of the winners, the people of Greece. Here's something you probably didn't know about Greece. They don't have enough cemetery space. And cremation is not very popular there. So what they do is, when you die, you're buried in the ground.
第一幕，家庭墓地。现在我们从特洛伊战争的输家转移到赢家——或者说，赢家的后代，希腊人民。这里有一些你可能不知道关于希腊的事。他们的墓地空间不足。而且火葬在那里不太受欢迎。所以他们做法是，当你去世后，你会被埋在土里。
And then three or four years later, your family gets together and digs up your bones. Get you out of the ground, give the space to somebody else. One of the producers of our show, Lina Misitzis, her parents were both born in Greece. And she traveled there in September with them to do this for the very first time.
然后三四年后，你的家人会聚在一起挖出你的骨头。把你从土里弄出来，把这个位置腾给别人。我们节目的制片人之一，莉娜·米西齐斯，她的父母都出生在希腊。九月份她和父母一起去那里，第一次做这件事。
We're in a rental car driving from Athens to a small village in the south called Stoupa. It's about four hours away. My dad's driving. I'm in the front seat. Mom's in the back. We're on our way to Stoupa to exhume my grandmother, my father's mom. My dad's talking about the cost of gas, how much money it'll cost to keep this car full of gas, also other things about gas.
我们在租来的车里，从雅典开车前往南方的一个小村庄叫斯图帕。大约四个小时车程。我爸爸在开车。我坐在前座。妈妈在后面。我们正要去斯图帕挖掘我的祖母，也就是我爸爸的妈妈。我爸爸在谈论油费，这辆车加满油要花多少钱，以及其他关于油的事情。
There's no gas station here.
这儿没有加油站。
I recognize this conversation not for its content, but for its design. My dad, an extraordinarily kind and thoughtful person, he fills so much space with small talk. I hate small talk. Today, September 19th, is my mom's 66th birthday. We weren't supposed to exhume my grandmother on my mom's birthday. It was supposed to happen tomorrow. But because of forecasted rain, we're doing it today.
我认出了这段对话，不是因为它说了什么，而是因为它的套路。我爸爸是一个非常善良体贴的人，他用闲聊填补了太多的空间。我讨厌闲聊。今天是9月19日，是我妈妈66岁的生日。我们本不该在妈妈生日那天挖掘祖母的。本该是明天。但因为预报有雨，我们今天就做了。
What a gift for my birthday.
真是个生日大礼。
This will not be the last time she brings up her birthday. My grandmother spent the last third of her life dying. Her disorder was never successfully diagnosed. It kind of looked like Parkinson's. It kind of looked like Huntington's. But it was neither of those things. A caretaker, a distant cousin named Crisoula, would come and change her diapers twice a day, feed her baby food. Growing up, I was kind of afraid of my grandma. She'd lost her ability to speak, and she just kind of looked at me, and moaned, and cried.
她不会是最后一次提起她的生日。我祖母生命的最后三分之一是在死亡中度过的。她的疾病从未被成功诊断出来。它看起来有点像帕金森病。有点像亨廷顿舞蹈症。但两者都不是。一位远房表亲，名叫克里斯拉的看护人，会每天两次来给她换尿布，喂她婴儿食品。在成长过程中，我有点怕我的祖母。她失去了说话的能力，她只是盯着我看，呻吟，哭泣。
It's called chorea. When you have it, you cannot control your movements. You have jerking, uncontrollable movements of your hands and face.
这叫舞蹈症。当你得了这个病，你无法控制自己的动作。你的手和脸会有抽搐的、无法控制的动作。
And chorea is actually a Greek word, right?
舞蹈症其实是一个希腊词，对吧？
Chorea, yeah. Chorea.
舞蹈症，是的。舞蹈症。
That means I'm dancing.
这意味着我在跳舞。
It means I'm dancing, my mom says. She's always answering questions for my dad. I think he prefers it that way.
它意味着我在跳舞，我妈妈说。她总是代替爸爸回答问题。我觉得他更喜欢这样。
Mommy remembers better than I do, and I have to pay the toll now.
妈妈记得比我好，我现在得去交过路费了。
Pay the toll.
交过路费。
My mom didn't go with my dad to his mother's funeral. He went alone. I figured he'd be doing the second funeral, this reverse funeral, alone, too. And while I don't know what this process looks like at all, the thought of my dad exhuming his mother's body by himself, it just sounded sad.
我妈妈没有陪我爸爸去参加他母亲的葬礼。他独自一人去的。我想他也得独自完成这第二次葬礼，这种逆向葬礼。虽然我根本不知道这个过程是什么样的，但想到我爸爸独自挖掘他母亲的尸体，这听起来太悲伤了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
And so a few months ago, I decided I wanted to go with him. To be there for him. In my fantasy of it I'd be by his side, holding his hand, patient, curious even. Which isn't how it usually goes between us. My dad doesn't talk about his feelings too often. Half the time, I think he doesn't even know what they are. But then when I'm around him, I get impatient.
所以几个月前，我决定陪他一起去。为了支持他。在我的幻想中，我会陪在他身边，握着他的手，耐心，甚至好奇。但这通常不是我们之间的相处方式。我爸爸不常谈论他的感受。我觉得有一半时间他甚至不知道那是什么。但当我待在他身边时，我会变得不耐烦。
I guess this moment just seems really big, like a chance for us to be different with each other. But then when my mom found out that I was going, she decided that she would come, too. She doesn't want to pass up a chance to see me. She agrees to sit in the backseat while I try talking to my dad about what we're on our way to go do.
我想这个时刻看起来真的很重大，就像是我们彼此改变的一个机会。但后来我妈妈发现我要去，她决定也一起去。她不想错过见我的机会。她同意坐在后座，而我试图和爸爸谈论我们此行的目的。
In general, I'm not very comfortable in cemeteries.
总的来说，我在墓地里不是很自在。
Why not?
为什么不呢？
I don't know. I never was.
不知道。我从来都不自在。
Right, most people are uncomfortable in cemeteries. But for some reason, I just can't let it go.
好吧，大多数人在墓地里都不自在。但出于某种原因，我就是放不下这个问题。
Well, there must be a reason.
嗯，一定有个原因。
I don't believe so, no. You expect me to say more now. I don't know what to say.
我不这么认为，没有。你现在期待我说更多。我不知道该说什么。
No, you're fine. You're fine. You don't have to say anything.
不，你很好。你很好。你不必说什么。
I'm driving, too.
我也在开车。
You are driving.
你是在开车。
This back and forth is so typical, it's practically scripted. He tries to play along to engage. But I never think it's enough.
这种一来一回太典型了，几乎像剧本写好的一样。他试着配合参与。但我总觉得这还不够。
Do you know when your mom was born?
你知道你妈妈是什么时候出生的吗？
I believe 1928.
我想是1928年。
Actually, she was born in 1925.
实际上，她是1925年出生的。
Was she a smoker?
她抽烟吗？
No, she never smoked.
不，她从不抽烟。
Was she a drinker?
她喝酒吗？
I don't think she ever had any alcohol.
我不认为她喝过任何酒。
What did she do for fun?
她有什么娱乐活动？
Cross stitch.
十字绣。
Did she have friends?
她有朋友吗？
Very few.
很少。
Do you think she was depressed?
你觉得她抑郁吗？
Um-- I guess so. I never thought in these terms at the time, but yeah, I guess now you mention it, I think so. Probably she was.
嗯——我想是吧。我当时从未从这个角度思考过，但是的，我想现在你提起它，我觉得是。也许她是吧。
Was she a good mom?
她是个好妈妈吗？
I don't know. I guess. Uh-oh.
我不知道。我想是吧。哦哦。
What's wrong?
怎么了？
The check engine light comes on in the rental.
租车的发动机检查灯亮了。
Check engine oil.
检查机油。
It derails the rest of the car ride, each conversation circling back to the potentially faulty engine.
这让剩下的车程变得一团糟，每次对话都绕回到那个可能故障的发动机上。
We pull up to his family's village at 2:00. The woman who took care of my grandmother, Crisoula, is waiting for us in her yard. I haven't seen her in five or six years. She brings us cool water, keeps remarking on how absolutely different I look. I wouldn't recognize you anywhere, she says. Then a different family friend, Sotiroula, walks into the yard and joins us. You look exactly the same, she tells me. You haven't aged at all. So much of what there is to talk about is how old each of us is, what age looks like on us, and how we all wear it.
我们下午2点到达了他家族的村庄。照顾我祖母的那位妇女，克里斯拉，正在院子里等我们。我五六年没见她了。她给我们端来凉水，不停感叹我看起来多么不一样。她说，我无论如何都认不出你了。然后另一位家庭朋友索蒂劳拉走进院子加入我们。她对我说，你看起来一模一样。你一点都没老。这里谈论最多的就是我们每个人有多老，在这个年纪看起来是什么样，我们又是如何表现出老态的。
An hour later, we walk to the graveyard. It's me, my mom, my dad, Crisoula, and Sotiroula. Crisoula is carrying recycled plastic water bottles full of vinegar. She's also carrying small white brushes, the kinds you used to scrub dirty pots and pans. The village we're in looks like a caricature of a Mediterranean village. The roads aren't paved. The homes are all stone.
一小时后，我们走到墓地。是我，我妈妈，我爸爸，克里斯拉和索蒂劳拉。克里斯拉提着装满醋的回收塑料水瓶。她还带着小白刷，那种用来刷脏锅碗瓢盆的刷子。我们所在的村庄看起来就像一个地中海村庄的漫画。道路没有铺设。房屋都是石头建的。
You can see the Mediterranean Sea and the Taygetos Mountains from anywhere. The graveyard is connected to the church, which is connected to the school. Everything is dusty. The graves are all white. The buildings are all white.
从任何地方都能看到地中海和塔伊耶托斯山脉。墓地连接着教堂，教堂连接着学校。到处都是尘土。坟墓全是白色的。建筑物也全是白色的。
The grave digger is already at my grandmother's grave. He's wearing blue overalls and a yellow T-shirt. He has on a Yankees cap. His name is Arturo. Baseball isn't really a thing in this country. I can't imagine where he got the hat. My mom walks to the opposite end of the cemetery, where she sits down on a stranger's grave beneath some shade.
掘墓人已经在祖母的坟墓那里了。他穿着蓝色工装裤和一件黄色T恤。他戴着一顶扬基队的帽子。他叫阿图罗。棒球在这个国家并不流行。我想不出他从哪弄来的帽子。我妈妈走到墓地的另一端，坐在树荫下别人的坟墓上。
She doesn't want to see my grandmother's body, she says. It's a small cemetery, just a few dozen graves. And they're all so loved, which makes sense. No one is buried for long here, so as long as the body's in the ground, people come to visit. Each plot has photos on it, bottles of beer, and liquor, potted plants, candles, many of them lit. My dad hobbles around, inspecting the other graves to see who else has died since the last time he was here.
她说她不想看到祖母的尸体。这是一个小墓地，只有几十个坟墓。而且它们都受到珍爱，这很有道理。在这里没有人被埋葬很久，所以只要尸体还在地下，人们就会来探望。每个墓地上都有照片，啤酒和烈酒瓶，盆栽，蜡烛，其中许多还亮着。我爸爸一瘸一拐地走着，检查其他坟墓，看看自从上次他来这里后还有谁去世了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Whenever he recognizes a name, he confirms with Crisoula that yes, the person whose name is written on the gravestone is, in fact, dead.
每当他认出一个名字，他就会跟克里斯拉确认，是的，墓碑上写着名字的人确实已经去世了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
One of the graves is occupied by the priest who blessed my grandmother's body just a few years ago at her funeral.
其中一个坟墓的主人是几年前在我祖母葬礼上为她祈祷的牧师。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
"But I just saw him," my dad says, "at my mother's funeral. He's dead?"
“但我刚见到他，”我爸爸说，“在我母亲的葬礼上。他死了？”
All week, people have been saying to us, [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH], which I understand as, "We hope she's melted." Such a strange way to say, I hope your grandmother's flesh and organs have finished decomposing. My taxi driver who picked me up from the airport in Athens told me that at his aunt's exhumation, he'd had to wash the residual skin and blood off of her bones, which is a thought so unnerving, I don't think I fully fathomed it. Still, I stand beside the grave digger, defiant, as though to say, even if none of you are going to look, I'm going to look.
这一整周，人们一直在对我们说[非英语谈话]，我的理解是，“希望她已经融化了。”这是一个多么奇怪的说法，我希望你祖母的肉体和器官已经完成了分解。雅典机场接我的出租车司机告诉我，在他阿姨的开棺仪式上，他不得不把残留在骨头上的皮肤和血洗掉，这个想法太让人不安了，我觉得我没有完全体会到。尽管如此，我还是倔强地站在掘墓人旁边，仿佛在说，即使你们都不看，我也要看。
For more than an hour, there's nothing to look at. Arturo's just shoveling out rocks and dirt, placing it all in a pile at the foot of the grave. And I stand there, sweating, waiting for whatever is going to happen. My mom keeps sitting on her shady grave. My dad keeps reading the names off of headstones, though he's running out of names he recognizes. Growing up, this village, like the rest of Greece, was homogeneous. Everyone was related to everyone. But now, there are Balkan migrants living here, retired Germans and Brits, even some expats from the US. In Greece, they're called [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH], strangers.
一个多小时过去了，什么也看不到。阿图罗只是铲出石头和泥土，把它们全部堆在坟墓脚下。我站在那里，汗流浃背，等待着将要发生的事情。我妈妈继续坐在那个阴凉的坟墓上。我爸爸继续从墓碑上读名字，尽管他能认出来的名字快用光了。在成长过程中，这个村庄和希腊的其他地方一样，是同质化的。每个人都和每个人有亲戚关系。但现在，这里住着巴尔干移民，退休的德国人和英国人，甚至还有一些来自美国的外国人。在希腊，他们被称为[非英语谈话]，陌生人。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
They're listing off all the foreigners in here.
他们正在列出这里所有的外国人。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Eventually he walks over to where I'm standing, I think to check in on me.
最后他走到我站的地方，我想是来看看我。
Do you want me to say something out loud?
你想让我大声说出来吗？
No, I want you to just be normal. How do you feel?
不，我只想让你表现得正常点。你感觉如何？
Kind of numb.
有点麻木。
Yeah.
是啊。
Kind of numb.
有点麻木。
You know what I'm saying? I'm not saying the--
你知道我在说什么吗？我不是说那个——
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
He interrupts himself to say, "Look, there's water to drink." Then he walks away to the corner of the cemetery, where Crisoula has set up a makeshift water station. Arturo's dug 4 or 5 feet down and switches his shovel out for what looks more like an ice pick.
他打断自己说，“看，有水可以喝。”然后他走到墓地的角落，克里斯拉在那里搭了一个简易供水站。阿图罗已经挖了4或5英尺深，把铲子换成了一把看起来更像冰镐的工具。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
"We're getting close to the body now," he says. Dad walks over to stand with me. So does Crisoula. My mom comes over, too, which at first, I find shocking, but it's not really. She doesn't want to feel left out.
“我们快到尸体了，”他说。爸爸走过来和我站在一起。克里斯拉也过来了。我妈妈也过来了，起初我觉得很震惊，但其实并不奇怪。她不想有被排除在外感。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
"Slowly," Crisoula says.
“慢点，”克里斯拉说。
That is the coffin.
那是棺材。
That's the flowers that they put on the coffin, right?
那是他们放在棺材上的花，对吧？
Yeah.
是的。
Crisoula is hovered over Arturo, holding out a giant trash bag. She's collecting any pieces of coffin that haven't disintegrated in the past few years. For a moment, everyone is silent.
克里斯拉蜷缩在阿图罗身上，拿着一个巨大的垃圾袋。她在收集过去几年里没有完全风化的棺材碎片。片刻，所有人都沉默了。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
"It's time," Arturo says. "Be very careful. The body is ready."
“时候到了，”阿图罗说。“小心点。尸体准备好了。”
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Arturo pulls my grandmother's head out of the ground and hands it to Crisoula. There's still some hair on it, but no skin. She plucks the hair off the skull, which isn't white like the fake skeletons I remember from science class. It's dark brown, closer to black. My grandmother's eye sockets are filled with dirt. Crisoula rubs her skull clean with a scrubby brush. She holds it up to us to look at, pointing out my grandmother's gold teeth, still intact. It's like she's saying, see? It's really her.
阿图罗把祖母的头从土里拉出来，递给克里斯拉。上面还有一些头发，但没有皮肤。她把头发从头骨上拔下来，头骨并不像我科学课上记得的那种假骷髅是白色的。它是深棕色的，接近黑色。祖母的眼眶里填满了泥土。克里斯拉用刷子把她的头骨刷干净。她把它举给我们看，指着祖母金色的牙齿，依然完好无损。就好像她在说，看，真的是她。
Arturo keeps pulling out pieces of coffin and pieces of my grandmother. They're not connected to anything anymore. Most of these bones have come loose. He pulls out some ribs, a shoulder bone, what I think is a femur, but my mom says is a clavicle. Crisoula collects each bone one by one and lays them out in the sun.
阿图罗继续拉出棺材碎片和祖母的碎片。它们不再连接任何东西了。大部分骨头已经松动了。他拉出一些肋骨，肩胛骨，我以为是股骨，但我妈妈说是锁骨。克里斯拉逐一收集每一块骨头，把它们摊在阳光下。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
"This was her left shoulder," she tells us. "See? You can still see the metal pin in her bone from when she got her surgery." For the next 20 or so minutes, she reconstructs as much of the body as Arturo can salvage. It's all so bizarrely DIY. Crisoula climbs into the grave with Arturo mid-dig to help pull out bones.
“这是她的左肩，”她告诉我们。“看？你还能看到手术时留在她骨头里的金属销。”接下来的20分钟左右，她尽可能地重组尸体，阿图罗能抢救多少就重组多少。这一切都怪异得像是DIY。克里斯拉在挖掘中途爬进墓穴去帮忙拉出骨头。
Neither of them is wearing gloves. "In Greece," Crisoula explains to me, "we bury the dead with their heads pointing west because that's where the sun sets. And so that's where life ends." And this process of exhuming, it's conducted from the head down. The head comes out first, and Arturo works his way down the body. The last thing that comes out are my grandmother's feet.
他们都没戴手套。“在希腊，”克里斯拉跟我解释说，“我们埋葬死者时，头指向西方，因为那是太阳落下的地方。所以那是生命结束的地方。”这个开棺的过程，是从头向下进行的。头先出来，阿图罗向下处理身体。最后出来的是祖母的脚。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Both of my grandmother's socks, thick wool, are intact. This fabric doesn't disintegrate. She was buried in them on purpose, so that they'd know when they'd made it to the end.
我祖母的两只袜子，厚厚的羊毛袜，都完好无损。这种织物不会分解。她被埋葬时特意穿上它们，这样他们就知道什么时候到达了尽头。
Those are her socks?
那是她的袜子？
Yes.
是的。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Do you mind saying it in English?
你不介意用英语说吗？
She's emptying the sock so all the little bones from the feet can come out. See all the bones? The heel of the toes, and the-- oh, my goodness.
她正在清空袜子，以便脚部所有的小骨头都能出来。看到所有的骨头了吗？脚跟的骨头，还有——哦，天哪。
We stand there for a moment, watching Crisoula wipe down each bone. It's jarring how practical this whole process is, how unceremonious it feels to bury your loved ones in socks so that you'll know when you've finished un-burying their remains.
我们站在那里片刻，看着克里斯拉擦拭每一块骨头。整个过程是如此实际，让人震惊，把亲人埋在袜子里，这样你就知道什么时候清理完了他们的遗骸，这种感觉是如此非正式。
You OK?
你还好吗？
I'm sitting down. Yeah.
我坐下来了。是的。
I'm OK.
我还好。
This is going to be with me for a while now, but.
这会一直伴随我一段时间，但是。
This is not scary.
这并不吓人。
"This is going to be with me for a while," my dad says, right as my mom says, "This is not scary." I feel annoyed with my mom for stepping on his answer, on what he might have said, just so she can say that she's fine, that she's not scared. But then when my dad does have the space to tell me what he's feeling, he can't seem to catch his breath.
“这会一直伴随我一段时间，”我爸爸说，正当我妈妈说“这并不吓人”时。我对妈妈打断他的回答感到恼火，他可能还会说些什么，就为了说她很好，她不害怕。但当爸爸确实有机会告诉我他的感受时，他似乎无法平静呼吸。
The skull, it's--
头骨，它——
The skull--
头骨——
--all her bones.
——她所有的骨头。
--it's all her bones.
——它全是她的骨头。
When it first came out, it looked like a coconut because there was still hair on it.
当它第一次出来时，它看起来像一个椰子，因为上面还有头发。
Yeah, it has hair on it. Yes. All right.
是的，它上面有头发。是的。好了。
What's wrong?
怎么了？
I'm OK.
我还好。
"I'm OK," he's saying. Crisoula tells us that it's over. We can go. While we're away, she'll keep scrubbing the bones, first with water, then with vinegar. She'll place them in a small box that'll go in a shed, which holds the remains of all the other exhumed residents of this graveyard, many of them people my grandmother grew up knowing, and some [NON-ENGLISH], some foreigners.
“我还好，”他说。克里斯拉告诉我们结束了。我们可以走了。当我们离开时，她会继续清洗骨头，先用水，然后用醋。她会把它们放在一个小盒子里，放在棚子里，里面装着这个墓地所有其他被挖出来的居民的遗骸，其中许多是我祖母从小就认识的人，还有一些[非英语]，一些外国人。
I asked to see the shed, which really is just a shed, like where a friend's dad might keep his lawnmower, except for this one's got stacks and stacks of small boxes in it. Some are labeled. Many aren't. It doesn't seem like anyone visits this place.
我要求看那个棚子，它真的只是一个棚子，就像朋友爸爸放割草机的地方，除了这个棚子里堆着一叠又一叠的小盒子。有些有标签。很多没有。似乎没有人探望这个地方。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
Later, we'll come back to the cemetery to watch a priest, one that's alive, bless my grandmother's bones. One last goodbye. But for now, we three-- me, my mom, and my dad-- we pile back into the rental to drive to a neighboring village where we're staying for the next few days. And suddenly, my dad starts to talk about his feelings.
后来，我们会回到墓地看一位牧师，一位活着的牧师，为祖母的骨头祈祷。最后一次告别。但现在，我们三个——我，我妈妈，我爸爸——我们挤回租来的车，开车去邻近的村庄，我们在那里住几天。突然，我爸爸开始谈论他的感受。
And I just-- it was-- that was my mom.
我只是——那是——那是我的妈妈。
That was what?
那是什么？
That was my mom at some point. It's-- I was expecting it to be-- I don't know. I feel peaceful. I was expecting it to-- I did not know what to expect. I spent a lot of hours up at nights. I'm just muddled, you know?
那是我的妈妈，在某个时候。我本以为会是——我不知道。我感到平静。我本以为会——我不知道该期待什么。我晚上失眠了很多小时。我只是思绪混乱，你知道吗？
No, it's-- no, I hear what you're saying. I thought it was going to be upsetting, and it really wasn't for me.
不，我听到了你在说什么。我以为会让人不安，但对我来说真的没有。
And that was it. It was over. Not as traumatic as we thought it would be.
就是这样。结束了。没有我们想象的那么痛苦。
Here is a sign for it.
这儿有一个标志。
And here, in this car, all my family has is what we've always had. I start fussing over my dad's driving.
而在这辆车里，我的家人所有的只是我们一直拥有的。我开始对我爸爸的驾驶唠叨起来。
Well, when that sign that said--
嗯，当那个标志写着——
Yeah.
是的。
[NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
[非英语谈话]
You'll go left.
你会向左走。
We'll need to look for it.
我们需要找找看。
And then I start feeling carsick. Every bad habit I have with my parents begins to bubble up. And instead of doing the thing that I came here to do, instead of engaging with my dad, I become a kid again, complaining about an upset stomach.
然后我开始晕车了。我和父母相处时的每一个坏习惯都开始涌现。我没有做我来这里要做的事，没有和爸爸交流，反而像个孩子一样，抱怨胃部不适。
I'm going to throw up. I can't. And it says here, Dad.
我要吐了。我不能。标志就在这，爸爸。
Yeah, but I don't have a good--
是的，但我没有一个好的——
I want you to not drive if we don't know-- I'm sorry. My stomach feels like [BLEEP].
如果你不清楚路，我希望你别开车——对不起。我的胃感觉像[被消音]。
What is this? Somebody's seat belt is not on, or something? Is the door open?
这是什么？谁的安全带没系吗，或者别的？门开了吗？
Daddy, can we make a decision about what we're doing?
爸爸，我们能决定我们要干什么吗？
Listening back to this car ride, what sticks out to me most is the moment my dad tries doing the exact thing I came to Greece hoping for. He tries talking about his feelings. And he probably would have if I hadn't so quickly stopped listening.
回听这段车程，最令我印象深刻的是爸爸试图做我来希腊所期待的那件事的瞬间。他试图谈论他的感受。如果我没有那么快地停止倾听，他可能已经做到了。
Yes, Baba, but you have the phone.
是的，爸爸，但你有手机。
But you have the phone, and you can talk to her and she can say.
但你有手机，你可以和她说话，她可以说。
I think you should stop driving.
我认为你应该停止开车。
A couple days later, my last night in Greece with my parents, we decide to go out for dinner. And when we get to the restaurant, my mom pulls me aside to ask if I'm going to be good tonight, if I'm going to be present. "I'm always present," I lie. She says no. The only time I was present on this trip was at the cemetery. Otherwise, I'm the same as ever. We're all the same as ever. The only thing that's different, really, is we have one less day.
几天后，我在希腊和父母在一起的最后一晚，我们决定出去吃饭。当我们到达餐厅时，妈妈把我拉到一边，问我今晚能不能表现好点，能不能专注。“我一直都很专注，”我撒谎道。她说不。这次旅行中我唯一专注的时刻是在墓地。否则，我还是一如既往。我们每个人都一如既往。唯一不同的是，我们少了一天时间。
Lina Misitzis is a producer on our show.
莉娜·米西齐斯是我们节目的制片人。
Act Two, Next of Kindle. So our show today is about people unburying the past. And when people leave us, they don't just leave behind physical objects. Bim Adewunmi talked to a man about a digital excavation.
第二幕，Kindle的后事。今天的节目是关于挖掘过去的人们。当人们离开时，他们留下的不仅仅是实物。比姆·阿德温米谈到了一个关于数字挖掘的故事。
Gloria Wayne was a voracious reader. Her son, Dave, has vivid memories of when he was six or seven, going with her to the library in the whirl, in Northwest England. They made a trip to Haswell Library every couple of weeks, returning and replenishing her stack of borrowed Mills and Boon novels. It was a habit Gloria maintained all through her long life. And so for Christmas, back in 2011, her sons got her a gift to aid in that habit-- a Kindle.
格洛丽亚·韦恩是一位贪婪的读者。她的儿子戴夫对六七岁时和她一起去英格兰西北部图书馆的记忆依然鲜活。他们每隔几周就会去一次哈斯韦尔图书馆，归还并补货她借来的米尔斯和布恩小说。这是格洛丽亚一生保持的习惯。所以在2011年圣诞节，她的儿子们送给她一件帮助这个习惯的礼物——一台Kindle。
Gloria was suspicious of online security in general, so they paid her Kindle with Dave's existing account and added an unlimited subscription so she could read whatever she wanted whenever she wanted to read it. Earlier this year, Gloria died. She was 83 years old. I spoke to Dave on the phone about his mom, and we talked about the weird life admin that suddenly becomes super important after such a loss.
格洛丽亚对网上安全总体上持怀疑态度，所以他们把她的Kindle与戴夫的现有账户绑定，并添加了一个无限订阅套餐，这样她就可以随时随地阅读她想要的任何书。今年早些时候，格洛丽亚去世了，享年83岁。我和戴夫通了电话谈论他的母亲，我们谈到了在这样的损失之后突然变得极其重要的奇怪生活行政事务。
One of the first things that occurred to me, even though it may be the most insignificant, was that my mum hated wasting money. She would absolutely go mad if she thought that the next month's subscription was to come out, and she wasn't around to use it.
即便这可能是最微不足道的事情，我首先想到的事情之一是，我妈妈讨厌浪费钱。如果她认为下个月的订阅费要扣除，而她人却不在了，她绝对会疯掉的。
So only hours after she'd gone and still in a daze, Dave went to do the responsible thing, the thing he knew his mom would approve of-- cancel the Kindle subscription.
所以，在她去世仅几小时后，戴夫仍处于恍惚中，去做了负责任的事情，他知道母亲会赞同的事情——取消Kindle订阅。
And then I thought, well, just for old time's sake, let's have a look at what was there. So I clicked on to Library, and there before me I found 3,046 books. In the time period between Christmas 2011 when we bought the Kindle to her said passing on April 16th, she had purchased over 3,000 books, which was quite remarkable, really.
然后我想，好吧，为了旧情，看看里面有什么。所以我点开图书馆，出现在我面前的有3046本书。从我们购买Kindle的2011年圣诞节到4月16日她去世期间，她购买了3000多本书，这真的很了不起。
Dave had had an idea of his mom's literary interests. Her bookshelves contained a good amount of romance novels of the sort he remembered from childhood. He also used to get email notifications every so often. Remember, his account was linked to her Kindle all these years, but he didn't really pay attention to what his mother was buying. Romance novels, he'd kind of expected. But--
戴夫对母亲的文学兴趣有个大概的概念。她的书架上有不少他童年记忆中的那种浪漫小说。他以前也会偶尔收到电子邮件通知。记住，他的账户多年来一直与她的Kindle绑定，但他并没有真正关注母亲在买什么。浪漫小说，他早有预料。但是——
But what there was, was a number of-- I'm trying to put diplomatically really-- should we say, erotica. It was just erotica.
但是里面有一堆——我试图外交辞令一点——我们能说，色情读物吗？它就是色情读物。
And it wasn't just the vanilla stuff. It was a real pick and mix of sexual expression. If you're listening with kids right now, don't worry. This is not in any way X rated.
而且不仅仅是那种平淡的。那是性表达的真正大杂烩。如果你现在带着孩子在听，别担心。这绝不是X级内容。
I mean, not wanting to throw a whole cornucopia of acronyms at you, but there were MFM, MFF, FFM, triple MF, all kinds of different combinations of relationships and sexual encounters, which was quite staggering, to be honest. You know, there was no one aspect. There was no one peccadillo that she got drawn to. It was a whole variety.
我的意思是，不想向你们抛出一堆缩写，但有MFM, MFF, FFM, 三人MF，各种不同组合的关系和性邂逅，老实说，这真是令人震惊。你知道，没有单一的侧重点。没有她特别沉迷的一种嗜好。而是一个完整的集合。
Dave tweeted about both his mother's passing and his inadvertent inheritance of a library of what he described tongue in cheek as magnificently epic sleaze. He concluded it with a tribute of sorts. "Mother," he wrote, "I raise a glass."
戴夫发推文讲述了母亲的去世以及他意外继承的图书馆，他半开玩笑地将其描述为“极其史诗般的下流内容”。他用某种致敬结束了这段推文。“母亲，”他写道，“我举杯致敬。”
Discovering the library made Dave curious. He and his mother shared similar tastes in music and film. Maybe there would be unlikely common ground here, too. He decided to make a project of his discovery. He would delve into his mother's virtual stack of saucy literature-- his words-- and maybe find one more thing they had in common. It wasn't especially taxing.
发现图书馆让戴夫好奇起来。他和母亲在音乐和电影上有相似的品味。也许这里也有意想不到的共同点。他决定把他的发现作为一个项目。他会深入母亲的虚拟色情文学堆——用他的话说——也许能找到他们共同的另一件事。这并不特别费劲。
You know, it was only a fairly short kind of thing. It was a 90-minute endeavor. So for 100 days on the run, I read a book each day.
你知道，这只是一个相当短的事情。这是一个90分钟的尝试。所以连续100天，我每天读一本书。
Do you have a favorite title? Was there any title that stuck out to you as just either abominably bad or actually fantastically good?
你有一本最喜欢的书名吗？有没有哪个书名让你觉得要么糟透了，要么好得离谱？
Probably a bit of both, to be honest. And that's, without doubt, Spanked by the Italian Mob.
老实说，大概两者都有。毫无疑问，那是《被意大利黑手党狠狠鞭打》。
[LAUGHS]
[笑]
Superb.
棒极了。
Because it does what it says on the page. It is literally about a girl who wants to be spanked by the Italian mob. And that's the beginning, middle, and the end. I mean, the whole series, to be honest, of Spanked by books. There's about six or seven--
因为它名副其实。它讲的真是一个女孩想要被意大利黑手党鞭打。从头到尾就是这样。老实说，这一整套“鞭打”系列……大概有六七本——
Wow.
哇。
--with this poor girl being spanked by a variety of men.
——讲的是这个可怜的女孩被各种男人鞭打。
I checked out the series, by the way. It's by Alexis Starr. The actual title Dave is thinking about is Spanked by the Irish Mob. Each book features a heroine looking for a spanking and getting it from the Yakuza, a Navy SEAL, an unaffiliated mob boss, and others. As Dave read more books, he found himself enjoying some of them enough that he started to have a few favorites.
顺便说一下，我查了这个系列，作者是亚历克西斯·斯塔尔。戴夫想的那个书名其实是《被爱尔兰黑手党鞭打》。每一本书的女主角都在寻找被鞭打的体验，并从黑帮、海豹突击队、未关联的黑帮老大和其他人那里得到满足。随着戴夫阅读更多的书，他发现自己挺喜欢其中一些书的，甚至开始有了几个最爱。
Opposing Briefs was an MM romance that was quite fascinating.
《对立摘要》是一本MM（男男）言情，非常迷人。
That's great.
那太棒了。
I quite liked the playful nature of the title. That was written by Ian Finn. I did like that a great deal. And a one called-- one written by Anyah Omah, called Sexsomnia, Sleepless in Manhattan. And that was very good indeed as well, which was a lighter tone and slightly less of an explicit nature to it.
我相当喜欢这个书名的俏皮性质。那是伊恩·芬恩写的。我非常喜欢它。还有一本——一本由安雅·奥马写的，叫《性睡症，曼哈顿无眠》。那确实也非常棒，它的基调较轻，色情性质稍微少了一点。
Now that the 100 book challenge is over, Dave has kept his mom's subscription going, and he's still reading her books. They're a reminder that his mom was more than just his mom. She was a real whole person with her own quiet obsessions.
现在100本的挑战已经结束了，戴夫保持了他母亲的订阅，他还在读她书架上的书。它们提醒他，他的母亲不仅仅是他的母亲。她是一个拥有自己安静痴迷的真正完整的人。
In reading these books, do you feel is it helping? Is it, in any way, a balm for you?
在读这些书时，你觉得有帮助吗？它们在某种程度上是一种抚慰吗？
Yeah, because it keeps her spirit present. You find yourself almost having a conversation, why do you read them? You read a particularly horrific and explicit line. You think, good grief, mother, what were you doing? So yeah, it does tend to extend that relationship. And while we can never reverse what happened, it does keep her memory more vivid.
是的，因为这让她的精神依然存在。你会发现自己几乎在进行对话，为什么你读这些？你读到一段特别恐怖且露骨的文字。你会想，天哪，母亲，你在做什么？所以是的，它确实倾向于延伸那种关系。虽然我们永远无法逆转所发生的事情，但它确实让她的记忆更加生动。
According to Dave, his mom was a homebody. And in her eighth decade, after a lifetime of working hard, Gloria liked to stay home, watch a bit of Murder She Wrote, and enjoy her smutty novels. Finding her library is a confirmation that his mom always did whatever the hell she wanted. And more than anything else, it just makes him admire her more.
据戴夫说，他的妈妈是个宅女。在她八十多岁的时候，在努力工作了一辈子之后，格洛丽亚喜欢待在家里，看一点《神探小天后》，享受她那些下流小说。发现她的图书馆确认了她妈妈总是随心所欲地生活。而除此之外，这只会让他更钦佩她。
Bim Adewunmi is one of the producers of our show. Coming up, the hip bone's connected to the-- it actually is not connected to anything in this case-- like, nothing at all. That's in a minute from Chicago Public Radio when our program continues.
比姆·阿德温米是我们节目的制片人之一。接下来，髋骨连接到——在这种情况下它实际上没有连接任何东西——什么都没连。稍后芝加哥公共广播电台将继续我们的节目。
It's This American Life. I'm Ira Glass. Today's show, Digging Up the Bones-- stories of people unearthing things from the past, trying to make sense of them. We've arrived at Act Three of our show. Act Three, The Case of the Curious Bone. David Kestenbaum has this story about a man obsessed with a single bone, a bone that is inexplicably large, really just too big to make any sense out of at all.
这里是《美国生活》，我是艾拉·格拉斯。今天的节目是《挖掘骨头》——关于人们发掘过去事物并试图理解它们的故事。我们到了节目的第三幕。第三幕，《好奇骨头的案件》。大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆讲述了一个关于男人沉迷于一块骨头的故事，这块骨头大得不可思议，真的大到根本无法解释。
It was a fragment of a bone, so old it had turned to stone. The man trying to puzzle it out was a naturalist and professor in England named Robert Plot. He writes about it in this beautiful meticulous book, The Natural History of Oxfordshire, published in 1677. "The curious bone," he writes, "was," quote, "dug out of a quarry in the parish of Cornwall and given to me by the ingenious Sir Thomas Pennyston." He writes that it seemed to be some part of a thigh bone, except way too big. It measured 2 feet and weighed almost 20 pounds.
这是一块骨头碎片，年代久远到已经变成了石头。试图解开谜团的人是英国的博物学家兼教授罗伯特·普洛特。他在1677年出版的一本精美细致的书《牛津郡自然史》中写到了它。“好奇的骨头，”他写道，“是从康沃尔郡教区的一个采石场挖掘出来的，由足智多谋的托马斯·彭尼斯顿爵士赠予我。”他写道，它看起来像是大腿骨的一部分，只是太大了。它长2英尺，重近20磅。
This is the 1600s, and no one in the world had a good explanation for a bone that big. Plot writes for almost nine pages in his book about the strange bone, and he is methodical in trying to reason out what the heck it is. First, he considers the possibility that maybe it's not a bone at all, but just some natural rock formation. Which is admirable. It's so easy to jump to conclusions.
这是1600年代，世界上没有人能对这么大的骨头有一个好的解释。普洛特在他的书中用将近九页的篇幅谈到了这块奇怪的骨头，他试图推断出这到底是什么，方法非常有条理。首先，他考虑了这根本不是骨头，而只是一种天然岩层的可能性。这是值得称赞的。人们太容易匆忙得出结论了。
But the more he studies it, it really does seem to be part of a colossal bone. He writes that it has the capita femoris inferiora and, quote, "the seat of the strong ligament that rises out of the thigh and gives safe passage to the vessels descending into the leg." And then inside the bone, there is what looks like marrow. He can see the marrow preserved inside. But what in the world was it from? Quote, "It will be hard to find an animal proportional to it," he writes.
但随着他研究的深入，它确实看起来像是巨大骨头的一部分。他写道它有“股骨下端的头”以及“从大腿升起并为下降到腿部的血管提供安全通道的强韧韧带的附着点”。然后在骨头内部，看起来有骨髓。他可以看到保存在里面的骨髓。但它到底是什么动物的呢？“很难找到与之成比例的动物，”他写道。
He runs through the possibilities, eliminating them one by one. Horse, oxen, too small. He considers something other people have suggested, that maybe the bone is from an elephant, perhaps brought over during the Roman invasions, back around 50 AD. He spends two pages on this possibility, but it seems unlikely to him. He's clearly read through lots of historical accounts.
他过了一遍各种可能性，一一排除。马，牛，太小了。他考虑了其他人提出的建议，也许这骨头来自大象，可能是公元50年罗马入侵期间带来的。他在这种可能性上花了整整两页，但他觉得不太可能。他显然读过很多历史记载。
Quote, "Suetonius in his life, where he is very particular concerning this expedition into Britain, mentions no such matter. There was one elephant, 'tis true," he writes, "sent as a present to King Henry the Third from the King of France in the year 1255, and perhaps two or three other elephants brought to England for show since then. But," quote, "whether it be likely any of these should be buried at Cornwall, let the reader judge. Also, if the bone is from an elephant," he writes, "where are the tusks?"
他说，“苏埃托尼乌斯在他的传记中，非常详细地提到了这次远征不列颠，但没有提及此类事宜。确实有一头大象，”他写道，“在1255年作为法国国王送给亨利三世国王的礼物，或许此后还有两三头大象被带到英国展示。但是，”他写道，“读者自己判断吧，它们中任何一头被埋在康沃尔郡的可能性大吗？还有，如果骨头来自大象，”他写道，“象牙在哪里？”
Finally, as he's writing it, he explains that an actual live elephant comes to town, which he examines and decides, no. Elephant thigh bone-- completely different shape. Definitely not elephant. And here, you can feel him starting to piece things together. He's on the edge of seeing this thing. He mentions other large bones. After the great fire in London in 1666, under the wreckage of St. Mary Will Church, quote, "there was found a thigh bone, now to be seen at the King's Head Tavern in Greenwich in Kent, much bigger and longer than ours."
最后，在他写作时，他解释说有一头真正的活大象来到镇上，他检查后决定，不。大象大腿骨——形状完全不同。绝对不是大象。在这里，你可以感觉到他开始把线索拼凑在一起了。他快要看清这个事实了。他提到了其他大型骨头。1666年伦敦大火后，在圣玛丽威尔教堂的废墟下，“发现了一块大腿骨，现在可以在肯特郡格林威治的国王头像酒馆看到，比我们的更大更长。”
And also, people had been finding unusually large teeth. In fact, people had been finding unusually large bones for centuries. There's one account by a Chinese scholar from the 300s BC, but none had a satisfying explanation.
而且，人们一直在发现异常大的牙齿。事实上，人们几个世纪以来一直在发现异常大的骨头。有一位中国学者在公元前300年的一份记载，但没有一个令人满意的解释。
It is remarkable reading Robert Plot's book to think how close he was to such a stunning fact about life on this planet. But you can know a lot and still not see. Sometimes you don't even know what you can't see. You just can't imagine the possibility of it, even when you were holding the thing in your hand. By the end of the section of the book, Plot has reasoned out the one remaining possibility, the only thing that makes any sense to him. The bones, they must have come from giants-- people just a little bigger. Which, I have to say, is way more sensible than the truth.
读罗伯特·普洛特的书，想到他离这个星球生命中如此令人震惊的事实有多近，真是非同寻常。但你可以知道很多事情，却依然看不见。有时你甚至不知道你看不见什么。你只是无法想象它的可能性，即使你手里拿着那个东西。在书的这一章结尾，普洛特推理出了唯一剩下的可能性，唯一对他来说说得通的事情。骨头，它们一定来自巨人——体型大一点的人。我必须说，这比真相要合理得多。
David Kestenbaum is the executive editor of our program. Robert Plot died in 1696. People didn't figure out the whole dinosaur thing for another 100 years. The bone Plot puzzled over was lost a long time ago, but from the drawings, scientists think that it was a Megalosaurus that lived in Cornwall some 170 million years before him, and yes, a thigh bone.
大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆是我们节目的执行编辑。罗伯特·普洛特死于1696年。人们直到100年后才搞清楚恐龙的事情。普洛特研究的那块骨头很久以前就丢了，但从图纸来看，科学家们认为那是一块生活在他之前约1.7亿年的巨齿龙的骨头，没错，就是大腿骨。
Act Four, Revision Quest. So we end our show today with somebody who dug up bones from her past, and then, years later, went back to the same site to dig them up again. Susan Burton explains.
第四幕，《修订任务》。我们今天以一个挖掘过往骨头的人结束我们的节目，几年后，她回到同一个地点再次挖掘。苏珊·伯顿解释道。
Jill's husband died a few years ago. They met in 1970 when Jill was 16 and he was 47. And in spite of the age difference, they were passionate about each other from the start. It was a happy marriage.
吉尔的丈夫几年前去世了。他们于1970年相遇，那时吉尔16岁，他47岁。尽管年龄差异很大，但他们从一开始就对彼此充满激情。这是一段幸福的婚姻。
That's one way to tell the story. Here's another. Jill's husband died a few years ago. They met in 1970 when Jill was 16 and he was 47. She was a student, and one evening after class, he kissed her. They started sleeping together. You might call him a predator or say he abused his power, but everything turned out OK. It was a happy marriage.
这是讲述故事的一种方式。这是另一种。吉尔的丈夫几年前去世了。他们于1970年相遇，那时吉尔16岁，他47岁。她是学生，一天课后，他吻了她。他们开始同居。你可能会称他为掠夺者或说他滥用权力，但一切都还好。这是一段幸福的婚姻。
Jill's a writer. Her full name is Jill Ciment. And years ago, when she was in her 40s, she published a memoir that told the story the first way. Now she's writing that story again and considering it from the second angle. Not to correct the record-- she's trying to understand why she wrote her story the way she did. The first memoir is called Half a Life. The one she's writing now is called The Other Half.
吉尔是位作家。她的全名是吉尔·西蒙特。几年前，当她40多岁时，她出版了一本回忆录，以第一种方式讲述了这个故事。现在她正在重新写作那个故事，并从第二个角度考虑它。不是为了更正记录——她试图理解为什么她当初那样写她的故事。第一本回忆录叫《半生》。她现在正在写的叫《另一半》。
When I wrote Half a Life originally, I wrote this thing from the depths of my heart. I was supposedly telling the truth, which I really deeply believed I was. But with the beginning of the Me Too movement, it was a kind of catalyst that made me think, what if I told my story again from this vantage point, from the vantage point of me being 66 and the vantage point of the world having completely changed.
当我最初写《半生》时，我是发自内心地写这个东西。我以为我是在讲真话，我也确实深信不疑。但在“Me Too”运动开始后，这成了某种催化剂，让我思考，如果我从这个角度，从我66岁的角度，从世界已经彻底改变的角度重新讲述我的故事会怎样。
Jill knew exactly where she wanted to start-- by writing down the story of their first kiss. What she wrote about it when she was in her 40s is not how she remembers it today. Here's what she remembers today. The night of that kiss, Jill and Arnold, her teacher, were in an art studio. It was an evening class. Most of the other students were retirees. The class had ended, and Jill was alone with Arnold.
吉尔确切地知道她想从哪里开始——写下他们第一次接吻的故事。她40多岁时写的内容与她今天记忆中的并不一样。这是她今天的记忆。那个吻的夜晚，吉尔和她的老师阿诺德在一个艺术工作室里。那是一场夜校。大多数其他学生是退休人员。课程结束了，吉尔和阿诺德独处。
And for the past six months, he'd been doing things like saying, I wish you were older, and not making sexual advances, but certainly making me aware he was attracted to me. And I was completely attracted to him, and all I did was fantasize about him. And so we went into his studio.
过去六个月里，他一直做一些事，比如“我希望你大点”，并没有进行性诱惑，但肯定让我意识到他被我吸引了。我完全被他吸引，我所做的一切就是幻想他。所以我们进了他的工作室。
Supposedly, he was going to give me the names of people-- I was about to drop out of high school and move to New York to be an artist. And he was going to give me the names of other artists who would become maybe mentors or hire me as an assistant. And as we got into the room, I remember he took my wrist and pulled me towards him, and we kissed. And I look back, and I realized I hadn't written it that way, OK? I had written it as if I had been the sexual aggressor.
据说是他要给我一些人的名字——我当时准备辍学去纽约做一名艺术家。他要给我其他艺术家的名字，他们可能成为导师或雇我做助手。当我们进入房间时，我记得他抓住我的手腕把我拉向他，我们吻了。我回顾过去，我意识到我并没有那样写，对吧？我是写得好像我是那个性侵略者一样。
Could you go ahead and read how you described the scene in Half a Life?
你能读一下你在《半生》中是如何描述那个场景的吗？
Absolutely. "On the last night of art class, I dawdled in the hall until the other students were finished. As soon as they were gone, I slipped back into the classroom and shut the door behind me. Arnold was leaning against a window frame, arms folded, eyes shut, yawning. This time I approached him without a hint of coyness, without the spark of a blush. I unbuttoned the top three buttons of my peasant blouse, crossed the ink splattered floor, and kissed him."
当然。“艺术课的最后一晚，我在走廊里徘徊直到其他学生都结束。他们一走，我就溜回教室并关上门。阿诺德靠在窗框上，双臂交叉，闭着眼睛，打着呵欠。这次我没有任何矜持，没有任何脸红的火花，走向他。我解开了农民衫上面的三颗扣子，穿过洒满墨水的地板，吻了他。”
Why did you write it that way in 1996?
为什么你在1996年那样写？
I don't know. I think I viewed myself as-- and I always have. I viewed myself as someone who was always in charge. I never felt powerless. And so maybe a way of illustrating that was to make me the sexual aggressor, at least as far as the kiss went. But I don't honestly know. I mean, that's why I'm writing this whole book, to try to figure out why it seemed the truth then. I would never have done it purposely, OK? It did seem the truth when I wrote it in 1996. Why it seemed the truth there is what interests me.
我不知道。我想我把自己看作——我也一直如此。我把自己看作一个总是负责任的人。我从未感到无能为力。所以也许说明这一点的方法就是让我成为性侵略者，至少在吻这件事上。但我真的不知道。我的意思是，这就是我写整本书的原因，试图找出为什么当时它看起来像是事实。我绝不会故意这样做，好吧？当我在1996年写它时，它确实看起来像事实。为什么它在那里看起来像事实是我感兴趣的。
One reason it seemed like the truth was that later, when Jill and Arnold slept together for the first time, she was the one who seduced him. She's certain of that. They both were. But that first kiss--
它看起来像是事实的一个原因是，后来，当吉尔和阿诺德第一次发生性关系时，是她诱惑了他。她确信这一点。他们都确信。但那个初吻——
When I look back on it, he did instigate this. And I don't know if I would have had the nerve at 16 and then later 17 to have acted upon all the things that I acted upon without him being the initial instigator.
当我回顾它时，确实是他发起的。我不知道如果不是他作为最初的煽动者，我是否能在16岁、后来17岁时有勇气去做出我所做的一切事情。
In making yourself the instigator, were you protecting him?
在让自己成为发起者时，你是在保护他吗？
I don't think so. I think that I was trying to tell the truth of my own desire. I saw him. I wanted him. And I went after him. And I don't think I knew how to reconcile that with the idea that he kissed me first.
我不这么认为。我认为我是试图讲述我个人欲望的真相。我看到了他。我想要他。我去追求了他。我不认为我知道如何将其与他先吻我这一想法调和。
In her 40s, Jill wanted to write a love story about love across a great age span-- this kind of story. It's almost always told from a man's point of view. Jill wanted to write it from the perspective of the young woman and also not make her the victim. And even though Jill still emphatically does not see herself as a victim, some of the choices she made in writing her first memoir seem startling to her now, like her account of a letter Arnold sent her after they slept together. "Dear Jill, are you ever coming back to class?" When she didn't respond, he called her. In the first memoir, Jill plays the anecdote for laughs.
40多岁时，吉尔想写一个关于巨大年龄跨度爱情的爱情故事——就是这种故事。它几乎总是从男人的观点讲述。吉尔想从年轻女人的角度写，也不让她成为受害者。尽管吉尔仍然坚决不把自己看作受害者，但她在写第一本回忆录时所做的一些选择现在对她来说似乎很惊人，比如她关于阿诺德在他们发生关系后写给她的信的描述。“亲爱的吉尔，你还回来上课吗？”当她没有回应时，他给她打电话。在第一本回忆录中，吉尔把这个轶事当作笑话。
The first time it's treated like, of course it's funny. What 47-year-old man is going to write a little girl at her house when her mother can open the mail? But when I rewrote it this time, what I saw was I saw a 47-year-old man having made love to a 17-year-old girl, after which he doesn't hear from her for a month. He writes a letter to her house, soliciting her again in this sort of fake love letter. And when he doesn't hear back from that little girl again, he calls her.
第一次它被处理得好像，当然很有趣。什么47岁男人会给家里的小女孩写信，而她母亲可能会拆信件？但当我这次重写它时，我看到的是一个47岁的男人在与17岁女孩做爱后，一个月没听到她的消息。他给她的房子写信，以这种虚假的爱书再次勾引她。而当他没有再次收到那个小女孩的回应时，他给她打了电话。
Now, in today's world, we would see that as a predator going after an underage girl. And when I think about that, I'm totally shocked. I'm shocked that I didn't see that the first time. But the end of a story really, really makes you change the beginning. And so I think that that's part of it. I think that part of the reason that I wrote it this way is because I was having a wonderful marriage. And part of the reason I wrote it this way was because in 1970, when all this stuff was happening, it wasn't as appalling for an older man to do this.
现在，在今天的世界里，我们会认为那是一个掠夺者在追逐未成年女孩。当我想到这一点时，我非常震惊。我震惊于我第一次竟然没有看到这一点。但故事的结尾真的、真的会让你改变开头。所以我认为这是其中的一部分。我认为我这样写的部分原因是，我当时婚姻生活非常美满。我这样写的部分原因是，在1970年，当所有这些事情发生时，年长男人这样做并不显得那么令人震惊。
Back in 1970, nobody ever said to Jill that they saw anything appalling in Arnold's behavior, at least not directly.
回到1970年，没有人对吉尔说他们觉得阿诺德的行为有什么令人震惊的地方，至少不是直接说的。
Here's the thing. I mean, I remember going to a party one time when we were first going out, where the hostess served everyone a martini and me a glass of milk. So I'm sure people noticed, OK?
事情是这样的。我的意思是，我记得我们刚开始交往时，有一次去参加聚会，女主人给每个人端上一杯马提尼，给我端上一杯牛奶。所以我敢肯定人们注意到了，好吧？
When Jill looked back at the first book, she was struck by the part she left out-- parts of scenes, the messier, more revealing parts, but other omissions, too, ones that are more profound, like about her father, who was the exact same age as Arnold. Most of the first book is actually about Jill's father. She only meets Arnold about 2/3 of the way through. By that point, her father had moved out. She rarely saw him. He was troubled, and explosive, and incapable of emotional connection, essentially absent from her life. I found her writing about him wrenching, but weirdly incomplete.
当吉尔回顾第一本书时，她被她遗漏的部分所震惊——场景的部分，更凌乱、更揭示性的部分，但也包括其他遗漏，更深奥的，比如关于她父亲，他恰好和阿诺德同龄。第一本书的大部分实际上是关于吉尔父亲的。她直到2/3处才遇到阿诺德。在那一点上，她父亲已经搬走了。她很少见到他。他很麻烦，易爆，没有情感连接的能力，基本上从她生活中消失了。我发现她写他的内容很痛苦，但奇怪地不完整。
It was just so clear that your art teacher was a substitute for your father in so many ways. And you don't write explicitly about this in Half a Life. And I wonder if you could talk about why.
很明显，你的艺术老师在很多方面都是你父亲的替身。你在《半生》中并没有明确写出这一点。我想知道你能不能谈谈原因。
I can't believe I didn't do it. I mean, I'm doing it now in this version. At 45, it seemed obvious. And the obvious in those days, I believed, made things less literary. God knows why, OK? But that's what I believed. And I just don't think it's true anymore. And I think the idea that a fatherless girl goes out and finds then a father and then uses that man to heal themself of having never been loved by an older man, I mean maybe I didn't know how to handle it at that age. Maybe it was impossible to do while both my father and my husband were alive.
我不敢相信我竟然没写。我的意思是，我现在在这个版本中写了。45岁时，这似乎很明显。而在那个年代，我以为明显会让事情不那么文学。天知道为什么，好吧？但那是我所相信的。我认为这不再是事实了。我认为一个没有父亲的女孩出去寻找父亲，然后利用那个男人来治愈自己从未被年长男人爱过的想法——也许我当时不知道如何处理。也许当我的父亲和丈夫都在世时，这根本不可能做到。
What has reexamining your story like this done to your picture of your husband, or your memories of him, or your perception of your marriage?
像这样重新审视你的故事，对你的丈夫画像、对他的记忆或对婚姻的感知产生了什么影响？
Well, I mean, it changes the picture because I can't now look at him without realizing the lines that he crossed. And at the same time, I'm really glad that we crossed those lines. I really question a lot of these inferences that it is always wrong. It wasn't wrong for me. And it will never change my feelings about it being an amazing marriage.
嗯，我的意思是，它改变了画面，因为我现在无法注视他而不意识到他跨越的界限。同时，我很高兴我们跨越了那些界限。我确实质疑很多关于它总是错的推论。它对我来说没错。它永远不会改变我对这是一场了不起婚姻的感受。
What things do you say in the new book that might have been hard for him to read?
你在新书中说了什么可能会让他难以阅读的事情？
Oh my god, the whole thing. I mean, I would never have written this book if he was alive. I mean, it would be so hurtful. Like in Half a Life, he seems like he has always been a successful older man. And to describe him as somebody who had a midlife crisis and was struggling to find himself again, I think would have been really painful for him to read.
哦天哪，整本书。我的意思是，如果他活着，我永远不会写这本书。我的意思是，那会非常伤人。在《半生》中，他看起来总是像一个成功的年长男人。而描述他作为一个中年危机、正在挣扎重新寻找自我的男人，我想对他来说阅读会非常痛苦。
Arnold was a painter. He was struggling as an artist when Jill met him. But he flourished in the years that followed.
阿诺德是一位画家。吉尔遇到他时，他作为艺术家正在挣扎。但在随后的几年里，他繁荣起来了。
It's interesting to hear you say that the thing Arnold would be hurt by is the depiction of him as a struggling middle-aged man, and not the questions about his role as possible predator or aggressor.
听到你这么说很奇怪，阿诺德会被伤害的是把他描述成一个挣扎的中年男人，而不是关于他作为掠夺者或侵略者的角色的疑问。
I don't think he was-- I mean, I don't think he ever thought of me-- but maybe he did. Who knows, OK? I think that he never thought of me as someone who wasn't as strong as him. And so I think he would be-- I think he'd be shocked and surprised by these nuances in which I'm looking back at our relationship.
我不认为他是——我的意思是，我不认为他曾经觉得我——也许他觉得。谁知道呢，好吧？我想他从未觉得我是一个不像他那样强大的人。所以我认为他会——我想他会因为我回顾我们关系时这些细微差别而感到震惊和意外。
The questions Jill's asking about what she included and what she left out, about what she realizes now that she didn't back then, those questions interest me because they're questions I'm asking myself right now, too. I'm almost exactly the same age as Jill was when she wrote Half a Life, and I have a memoir coming out in a few months. The book tells the story of my adolescence, but I assume it reveals just as much, if not more, about who I am now at 46 than who I was at 16.
吉尔问的关于她包含什么、遗漏什么的问题，关于她现在意识到而当时没有意识到的问题，这些问题引起了我的兴趣，因为它们也是我此刻正在问自己的问题。我几乎和吉尔写《半生》时的年纪一样大，我有本回忆录几个月后出版。书讲述了我的青春期故事，但我认为它揭示了更多关于我46岁现在的样子，而不是16岁时。
It's about the eating disorders that defined my teenage years, and if I'm being honest, my adulthood, too. Until recently, I'd never talked about this stuff with anyone. So in that way, the book is very exposing. But maybe what's not there is just as revealing. I know there's a lot I can't yet see, and I wanted to talk to Jill about that. I know that if I'd waited another five years, I would've understood more. And sometimes I wonder, should I have waited to tell my story until I understood it better?
它关于定义了我青少年时期，如果我诚实点说，也定义了我成年期的饮食失调。直到最近，我从未与任何人谈论这些。所以那样看来，这本书非常暴露。但也许不存在的内容同样具有揭示性。我知道有很多我还看不见的东西，我想和吉尔谈谈那个。我知道如果我再等五年，我会理解更多。有时我怀疑，我是不是该等到我理解得更好时再讲我的故事？
But I don't think I understand my story any better than I did at 45, OK?
但我认为我不比45岁时更理解我的故事，好吧？
Yeah.
是的。
I look back at my 45-year-old self, and I think, oh my god, she didn't have this information. I see how young I was at 45. I look at my 45-year-old self in much the same way that my 45-year-old self looked at my 16-year-old self. And it's a kind of compassionate view of who you were before you had all the information.
我回顾我45岁的自己，我想，哦天哪，她没有这些信息。我看到45岁时的我有多年轻。我观察45岁的自己，就像45岁的我观察16岁的自己一样。这是一种对你拥有所有信息前自己的慈悲视角。
Yeah. When you think about yourself at 45, how do you see your 45-year-old self now differently than she saw herself?
是的。当你想到45岁时的自己，你现在如何以不同于她看待自己方式来看待45岁的自己？
At that point, I was still thinking about the ascent of life. I was still moving in this forward motion. I was maybe at the height of my powers. And when I look back at that, I realized how delusional that is. What happens is you're writing at 45 from all the information experience that you've had. What I didn't have was the experience of taking my husband all the way to death.
当时，我还在思考生命的上升期。我还在这种向前的运动中。我可能处于权力的巅峰。当我回顾时，我意识到那有多么妄想。发生的是，你是用你所拥有的所有信息经验在45岁写作。我所没有的是带我丈夫一直走向死亡的经验。
In her new book, Jill's not just exploring the beginning of her relationship. She's writing about the end of it, too.
在新书中，吉尔不仅探索了她关系的开始。她也在写它的结束。
It's the second part of sleeping with your professor. It's the part where suddenly you go from being the young lover to the caretaker. And that's an entirely different transition. Taking someone to death, that's the most extraordinary experience there is. And so in some ways, who kissed whom first seems really small in the length of this journey.
这是和你的教授发生关系的第二部分。是你突然从年轻情人变成照料者的部分。那是一个完全不同的过渡。带某人走向死亡，那是存在的最非凡的经验。所以某种程度上，谁先吻谁在这一旅程中显得微不足道。
Jill always thought that the more interesting way to write memoir would be to return again and again to a monumental moment in a life, rather than telling the story in order all the way through. Revisiting a story doesn't necessarily make it any better, she says. But it does make it different. Even when we write about the past, we're always telling a story about the present, whether we mean to or not.
吉尔一直认为写回忆录更有趣的方式是反复回到生活中的一个重大时刻，而不是全程按顺序讲故事。她说，重新审视一个故事未必会使它变得更好。但它确实使它变得不同。即使当我们写过去时，我们也在讲述现在的故事，无论我们是否意图如此。
Susan Burton is one of the producers of our show. Jill Ciment's latest book is a novel called The Body in Question.
苏珊·伯顿是我们节目的制片人之一。吉尔·西蒙特的最新作品是一本名为《身体的问题》的小说。
Our program was produced today by Emanuele Berry and Neil Drumming. The people who put our show together today include Bim Adewunmi, Elna Baker, Susan Burton, Ben Calhoun, Dana Chivvis, Sean Cole, Damien Graves, Michelle Harris, Seth Lind, Jessica Lussenhop, Lina Misitzis, Katherine Raimondo, Nadia Reiman, Robyn Semien, Christopher Svetala, and Matt Tierney. Our managing editor is Diane Wu. Our executive editor is David Kestenbaum. Special thanks today to Theresa and Ryan Hynes.
今天的节目是由埃马努埃莱·贝里和尼尔·德拉明制作的。今天策划我们节目的人员包括比姆·阿德温米、埃尔娜·贝克、苏珊·伯顿、本·卡尔霍恩、达纳·奇维斯、肖恩·科尔、达米安·格雷夫斯、米歇尔·哈里斯、塞思·林德、杰西卡·卢森霍普、莉娜·米西齐斯、凯瑟琳·雷蒙多、纳迪亚·雷曼、罗宾·塞米恩、克里斯托弗·斯维塔拉和马特·蒂尔尼。我们的执行编辑是黛安·吴。我们的执行编辑是大卫·凯斯滕鲍姆。今天特别感谢特蕾莎和瑞安·海恩斯。
Our website, thisamericanlife.org, where you can stream our archive of over 680 episodes for absolutely free. And there's videos, and favorites lists, and tons of other stuff there, too. Again, thisamericanlife.org. This American Life is delivered to public radio stations by PRX, the Public Radio Exchange. Thanks, as always, to our program's co-founder, Mr. Torey Malatia.
我们的网站，thisamericanlife.org，在那里你可以完全免费收听我们超过680集的档案。那里也有视频、最爱列表以及许多其他东西。再次说明，thisamericanlife.org。《美国生活》由公共广播交换平台PRX分发给公共广播电台。一如既往地感谢我们节目的联合创始人，托里·马拉蒂亚先生。
He and I were running to an appointment this week on this 50-story skyscraper. We stopped first at the 45th story, where we thought our appointment was. We were sure it was 45. It wasn't right. Then we looked on 44, and 46, and 42, and 48. I was confused about which story. He was confused about which story.
这周我们正在赶去赴一个关于这座50层摩天大楼的约会。我们先在45层停了下来，我们以为约会在那里。我们确定是45层。不对。然后我们查看了44层、46层、42层和48层。我对哪一层感到困惑。他对比哪一层感到困惑。
I don't think I understand my story any better than I did at 45.
我想我不比45岁时更理解我的故事。
I'm Ira Glass. Back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是艾拉·格拉斯。下周带回更多《美国生活》的故事。